on va parler qu'ovide gestes barrières
confinement déconfinement couvre-feu ils
sont nombreux à ne plus en pouvoir en
france et c'est vrai que lors on t'a
pris des positions sur la copie d'un tu
n'oses en a parlé tout à l'heure et
c'est vrai que voilà tu es dans ton
livre tu dis je considère qu'il était
injuste d'empêcher des jeunes de vivre
normalement pour allonger de quelques
mois d'espérance de vie de vieillards
qui se lamentaient déjà dans des ehpad
alors qu'en cas de guerre on envoie les
jeunes au front sans demander aux vieux
de partir avec eux uniquement par
sociale et de l'humour à temps à la sncf
je voulais dire mais c'est vrai que t'en
parle dans son livre
et puis on a vu des interviews toi ou
c'est vrai que tu disais le colis est là
qu vide c'est vrai qu'on en fait trop
justement il ya ludovic toro qui est
avec nous un médecin qui voudraient
s'entretenir avec ça avec toi sur sa
faim font rien en fait on trompe en
fait-on trop avec le coville ludovic tu
peux rentrer les énergies vertes
toujours là toujours arriver dossier
vinci inquiète au tamis de bach mais
tout va bien
laurent c'est vrai que ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure toi pour ton on en fait
trop oui on en fait trop pas face sur le
fait qu'il faille évidemment protéger
les plus âgés et les gens qui sont
atteints de comorbidité qui
effectivement sont les premières
personnes ciblées mais on en a fait on a
fait trop peur et on continue à vouloir
faire trop peur aux gens moi c'est ça
qui me fait qui m'embête c'est pas c'est
pas les conditions sanitaires
évidemment qu'il faut faire les gestes
barrière ceci cela très bien mansat
quand même on en fait beaucoup là dessus
et je trouve que surtout on aurait mieux
fait depuis des années de mettre de
l'argent dans les hôpitaux saturent fait
mais on continue à nous dire à mes
pauvres il faut pas parce qu'il faut
former des gens il faut ce qu'il faut
cela dans ça si dans trois ans il ya
encore il ya encore des variants sais
quoi d'autre on continue on va nous dire
ça et ça fait ça fera trois lieux où tu
es d'accord avec laurent je suis
entièrement d'accord récurrent je trouve
que le bleu constat il est terrible en
fait ça fait un an qu'on est censé
combattre l'épidémie à coups de
confinement de vaccination de gestes
barrières on n'a jamais eu aussi peu de
liberté que maintenant on fait des
attestations pour tout et n'importe quoi
on l'aimait lesparre doha jusqu'au bout
il ya eu un tableau on est même le pays
tous pays confondus qui a été le plus
strictes en termes non seulement de
confinement mais de restrictions et ça a
été le pays le et si on n'a pas les
meilleurs résultats pour autant et comme
l'a dit laurent c'est normal maintenant
sur une attestation pour sortir son
chien enfin moi je trouve ça pas ça
normal et on s'installe vers une société
où on va trouver ça normal de se faire
confirmer reconfirmer
des confiné de se faire contrôler par la
police tout le temps je trouve ça et
eric est je pense dsk
moi je suis partagé parce que il n'ya
pas que les morts dus qu'au guide
il ya des gens qui gardent des séquelles
hadji séquelles extrêmement grave du duc
au vide et quand on a fait un tour dans
un hôpital et qu'on voit comment ça se
passe le csa here in aménas séparé jeudi
que j'ai partagé je viens à la deuxième
s'est en revanche il ya un côté
obsessionnel dans le cockpit c'est à
dire issa des émissions sur le co vide
qui ne nous apprennent rien chaque matin
j'ouvre la radio et je me dis mais
qu'est ce qu'ils vont trouver pour nous
parler du copil trouve à chaque fois un
angle et on n'apprend rien donc il ya un
côté obsessionnel et anxiogène mais moi
je prends et des chiffres on nous fait
peur avec des chimies mais moi je pense
que j'ai de l'année j'ai actualisé
ça c'est quand même terrible par exemple
à ces dernières semaines steelandt
brésil la stella non mais l'inde est
l'un de ces deux catastrophes la sonde
ont laissé une catastrophe en nombre de
morts bien sûr mais vous êtes frappé aux
portes et d'allemand ça je peux vous
dire actuellement
vous avez fait le calcul mais je les
aide à aller chiffres vérifiés vous à
100 millions le ratio est beaucoup plus
faible pour l'instant en had que chez
nous en france alors elle injustement
alors justement ludovic toro s'est en
fait en fait j'ai eu peur ouais pourquoi
que tu mettes m division face de moi tu
me dire face à face dit c'est pas
possible
non ça c'est laurent ça pose aucun
problème parce que j'ai passé mon après
midi à revoir les vidéos quand il a
parlé mais là rien d'extraordinaire
il a deux axes le premier c'est normal
ça tombe d'autant qu'il passait c'était
donc la première chose il faut sauver
tout le monde dans les hôpitaux bien sûr
oui il a raison et les autres faut qu'il
vive
oui il a raison après je me tenir après
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il dit bah
c'est vrai que ça fait des années qu'ils
hôpitaux ce qu'à sa gueule mais pas
seulement les hôpitaux toutes les
médecines dans notre pays mais encore et
donc on paye ça aujourd'hui c'est
surtout que moi ce qui me gêne c'est que
le gouvernement les gouvernements pas
seulement au gouvernement français nous
montre du doigt comme s'ils étaient
nommés responsables mais de ping alors
que ce sont eux les restaurants tu as
raison depuis le début on a accusé la
population depuis le début les jeunes
les moins jeunes les vieux c'est eux qui
sont les coupables alors que décideur
c'est pas nous bien éviter absolument
voilà autre chose que tu as 10 par
rapport à monsieur le roch nous a
raconté des bobs là dessus je peux que
t'accompagner dire que les jeunes
étaient évidents de son côté jo ils sont
pas plus mort que ça ce qu'il faut dire
et là je crois que tu a raison de le
dire il ya à peu près 400 milles coville
l'on sait dire que là on compte que les
morts il ya les co vino et j'te jure que
c'est une pathologie qui est très loin
et au delà de ça n'oubliez pas une chose
tous les gens qu'on n'a pas pris en
compte
dans les services hospitaliers depuis un
an vont avoir des maladies mais dévale
ali beaucoup plus avancé parce qu'on
n'aura pas le temps les traiter donc ça
sera allé parler les autres maladies oui
qu'on a pas bien sûr donc forcément mais
on essaye pour ça en fait née voilà oui
c'est ça c'est moi il est pas du tout
complotistes il dit la vérité et ils
disent que je pense moi aussi moi
j'étais très dans le genre faut aller
vite faut faire mais va jouer le jeu
fait vacciner ouais et j'encourage
duléry bien sûr elles font et c'est ça
qui est tout à fait donc le problème
c'est que ça a duré trop longtemps il ya
eu trop d'erreurs
il ya eu des problèmes de communication
et c'est vrai tu l'as dit les chiffres
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas en notre
faveur
parce qu'au niveau européen va être
bientôt le deuxième pays où il ya le
plus de morts et excusez moi de vos
dessins au bout de trois confinement
c'est pas terrible quand vous me disiez
les feuilles les papiers à remplir
sérieusement on marche sur la tête a pas
un pays qu'on aurait osé faire ça non
plus ce sont les changer tous les jours
il y avait dix pages web
c'est pas comme ça qu'on traite les gens
gilles verdez retrouver contre nous -
laurent honnêtement vous m'avez choqué
sur la copie parce que je trouve que
parfois vous avez un
alors il est choqué très facile je sais
que je connais je peux des individus ses
maîtresses cadre là il est fiché mais je
te dis reste à la fois j'avais pas fais
mes lacets ils étaient choqués pour
donner des excuses mais presque avec
désinvolture
si on n'avait pas agi nous aurions une
hécatombe
alors oui on a fait des erreurs oui mais
voilà j'ai 100 dos et le beausset hobbit
est nouveau on a déjà pardon végète
huttérites que vous on a déjà une
hécatombe à son nom mais sans rien pire
mais et quand vous devez certain qu'on
en aurait eu beaucoup plus que ça pardon
à chaque fois je sais qu'on ressort cet
exemple là à chaque fois je sais qu on
le contredit mais a maintenant des
études bien plus sérieuses qui ont été
faites
les suédois ont moins confiné et ont été
beaucoup plus souple que nous et non pas
un ratio de 1 h avons dit oui mais c'est
un pays on peut pas le comparer aux
autres pays on devrait regarder aux
dalles au danemark ailleurs sauf que
justement la suède est le pays qui
ressemble plus aux autres pays d'europe
par rapport au danemark à la finlande et
aux autres pays donc franchement rien y
avait d'autres solutions que celle là je
vous jure je crois mais si c'est ça
m'empêche pas effectivement d'avoir de
la peine et et de penser à toutes les
victimes jamais je dis rien contre ça je
dis juste qu'on nous soule qui à un
moment qu'est ce qu'on va faire si ça
continue encore comme ça pendant des
années on va continuer à vivre ainsi un
sauvage a pas sortir après 19 heures
pour une écoute qui a des restaurateurs
j'ai vu aussi des patrons de
discothèques
sauvera demain les patrons de
discothèques et elle ne va pas ouvrir
leurs baux la wii les pauvres et
décevoir depuis le mois d'octobre ils
n'ont pas ouvert est ce que l'argent
j'interroge s'interroge le médecin les
restaurateurs oui les cinémas oui
répondent les salles de terre est la
question
vous savez tout en mettant une énorme
histoire les téléspectateurs connaissent
pas forcément la fois vous il avait des
gens moi aussi parce que je pourrais
vous aussi vous avez compris tous assez
fermé depuis octobre dernier
est-ce que ça a aidé à endiguer la
pandémie au nom avec nos dents parce que
tant qu'on n'a pas su depuis spa non il
fait ça s'adapte et s'adapter dire tout
simplement à un moment ça remet les
petits commerçants ont livré les grandes
surfaces ont été les uns sur les autres
on n'a pas su s'adapter et laisser la
possibilité de vivre alors qu'elle n'est
pas un gros risque de contamination
et c'est ça le vrai chef est aujourd'hui
bien là dessus c'est qu'on n'a pas su au
bout d'un an et demi on dit touring
pareil tout le monde faire non y'a des
négos sous il y avait deux ou trois
personnes qui rentraient il faut dire
que le commerçant est nettoyé comme
nettoyer c'était totalement débile dans
des départements où il y avait des
bistrots ps pas ouvrir l'oeil pas quatre
communes pendant qu'en région parisienne
tenait d'aller dans l'hypermarché faire
c'est quoi embêter à calais au sénégal a
toujours dit c'est ça que j'aime et j'ai
bien posté ça que je radote mais c'est
contre les incohérences de monsieur vers
en recevant nancy
s'il n'avait pas dû déjà remplacé
m'amusant au départ je pense il vous
dira que monsieur mac on n'aurait pas
gardé jusqu'au bout il va pas changer
tous les 4 matins au point de bonus est
obligé d'aller au bout avec lui mais
franchement je serais curieux d'avoir
les vraies relations entre monsieur
macro et monsieur verrou parce que
d'ailleurs on voit bien que le président
de république lui-même apprendre à
changer ligne depuis quelques mois
ouais il suit mois il suivra les
familles qui fait des faits samedi dans
ce moment là ça va un peu ça va un peu
loin dans l'autre sens parce que le
l'état est pas responsable de tout et la
population responsable de rien les
français ont respecté mais on a vu quand
même des scènes très choquantes
déconfinement c'était un délire tôt la
scop avérés les retours de les
réinstaller d'autun les gens est allé
d'un bug sans l été dernier trimestre
mais parce qu'on n'a pas
cet été on reste enfermé non pas du tout
un homme égale eu un laisser-aller voilà
qu'on appellerait ça faisait quand vous
avez dit à vivre mais je sais bien mon
billet à n'importe comment mourir
la raison essentielle pour laquelle on
mort c'est parce qu'on vit on m'a
répondu non mais si oui oui je la serre
a répondu ça dépend de nous c'est la
vérité mais à condition ça dépend de
nous si ça dépend du voisin
[Applaudissements]